probably one of the most quoted lines of
all of Shakespeare of course is neither
a borrower nor a lender be or too thin
on self be true well in context this is
said by a fatuous fool Polonius who's a
the pompous old windbag and Hamlet so
it's not meant to be taken as a truism
that you use so onto a needlepoint
sampler but if it works out of context
for you that's fine but just know that
it comes from somewhere else I remember
going to perform as a king lear a few
years ago and as i was leaving i heard a
couple speaking youngish couple and the
woman saying to the man i didn't know
this play had so many quotes but so much
of what we use in common parlance in
english today actually comes from
shakespeare originated in shakespearean
plays